so whenever we make decisions there are
two elements involved - when we evaluate
risk
the first is what's the probability that
I'll get it right okay and then the
second is you know what are the cost of
being wrong okay so if I'm deciding on
something like what school am I gonna go
to or what car I'm going to buy or what
I'm gonna eat for lunch the first is the
probability of getting it right like
what are the odds that I'll be happy
with the choice I make and that's a big
factor but the factor that produces the
most anxiety is the cost of being wrong
whenever there's a low cost of being
wrong we're not all that freaked out
about the odds so when when someone is
deciding on what they want for dinner or
if they're buying a toaster people don't
freak out about these things they tend
to be very risky and very experimental
because there's a low cost of being
wrong if I get it wrong if I buy some
cereal or a loaf of bread that I don't
like I can always just go back and you
replace it right but whenever the cost
of being wrong is really high well you
better get it right right because
because there's just a huge loss so we
worry more when we're doing things like
buying a house or buying a car or when
we're choosing to get married because
the cost of being wrong is really high
the traditional approach to education
has artificially driven up the cost of
getting it wrong because for the average
person that's 18 years old what's the
cost of making the wrong decision about
what you want to do with your life well
the cost is four five six years of your
life and anywhere from seventy to a
hundred thousand dollars that's a pretty
high cost so if you decide I like
teaching and you go to school and you
major in elementary education five six
years later you go out into the real
world and after a year of that you
decide you don't like kids well that's a
lot of time and a lot of money you just
invested into making that choice so it
puts a lot of pressure on young people
to make sure they think really hard
about it and get it right and that's
artificial because nature already has a
built-in mechanism for us to discover
what we like and what we want to do and
that's called experience that's called
experimentation and the cost of that is
actually relatively low and what we have
to do is return to a way of educating
young people that reduces the cost of
experimentation so they can discover
things in the way that human beings were
designed to does
through experimentation yes like what
you're talking about is building in
these these experiments that don't have
the maybe they have some cost but but
the benefit of that cost is almost
always going to outweigh what the actual
cost is even even in failure we learned
so much yeah so so you and I have been
going back forth and texts about every
cent NBA Finals and you know LeBron
James lost what is he three and six no
three and five some I don't know six
okay okay I know okay
that means he is now lost as many finals
as Michael Jordan is one I'm not
counting though and I and I sent you
this thing that John Mayer posted he
said you should look at this LeBron
James thing as a as actually an
encouraging thing because regardless of
the Jordan Rana thing we can all agree
that LeBron James is a great basketball
player one of the greatest of all time
and probably the greatest who's playing
today and even if you know nothing about
basketball those are just facts right
now especially if you know yeah but but
what's encouraging is you know what one
of the greatest people can fail this
many times and part of that is what
makes them great is being able to to go
back and say alright now I need to
figure this out again and what we're
talking about for your average person
who's 18 or 25 or 35 or 45 isn't they
don't have the same costs associated
with failures as LeBron James he has a
whole lot riding on on that failure we
can fail a whole lot and it doesn't
matter to millions of people like it
does to if failing like LeBron James
does yeah it's you know I look at that
that pressure we put on ourselves oh I
forgot to find the one thing I want to
do the rest of my life I don't know why
we have that ingrained in us I don't if
you were to tell me Josh or if you're
gonna tell ya if you were to tell me hey
Ryan
uh we're gonna be podcasting for the
rest of your life and that's the only
thing we're gonna do we're gonna you
know we're gonna get out this the
special that we're working on but but
we're just going to podcast like that
would be
a little scary for me now you know with
the minimus yes like we're the
minimalists we you know we talk about
simplicity we go on book tours we give
talks but there's a wide variety of
things that we are doing within the
minimalist it's not just this one task
yeah so you know I guess this is my way
of just telling our audience that you
don't have to pick something that you're
gonna do for the rest of your life in
fact I would say for the average person
it's probably they're probably not going
to do only one thing
you